[Music]
in yeah I set it news submitted by
fighting in a basement actress Jamie
press test Leah Priestley Presley
priestly priestly priestly rites
priestly yeah come on what are you
talking about you're the one who's
supposed to know the [ __ ] you say Elvis
I should I know me this whole time you
know cuz he's white that's why wait why
what she's one with me huh down to one
out didn't you I said madness you wanna
uh yeah I did with the original one I
never saw her in that are we talk about
Jason Priestley Oh am I talking about
no it's a girl no Jamie alright alright
alright oh it's Bruce Lee this girl is
that Presley uh priestly it doesn't
matter I don't have any idea that
honestly like Joe I know - uh no no
Jamie Priestley Presley parsley whatever
slammed online for admitting that her
oldest son is her favorite why what's
wrong that say that publicly because it
makes your other kids feel like [ __ ]
some character building that's that
that's the realest [ __ ] ever it's her
mom has a favorite favorite she's never
said it so she never made me feel more
like [ __ ] I forced my mom to tell me I'm
her favorite I did too but I knew it was
never true no but it's the realest [ __ ]
don't dramatize it that's a real thing
guys when I put your ankles are here
call your kid a shit-faced
wait go do it this is what he does it
feel so foolish is like all rather
Brazil is like that take it I did all
the way throw it
to get out okay yeah but some are a lot
sometimes I'm like that's when her [ __ ]
energy is really strong how did it help
you know you need to really break it off
yeah you got ready to scrape at all you
gotta grab it you're out your leg on a
tall dude that [ __ ] stuck on there yeah
we're gonna like that face of it yeah
that's the realest [ __ ] ever I don't
like it I'm all about it cool all right
so Jamie she has a 12 year old son named
desi he's pretty dope by her she also
has 21 year olds name Lennon and Leo
that's cool the older one oh they're too
young to [ __ ] remember who's the
favorite that's why sorry caption said
best time ever hanging with my favorite
son desi that's right I said it I have a
favorite son although I love all three
of my boys with everything I have in me
des and I have a special bond that no
one else will ever match because we've
grown up together hashtag firstborn
hashtag I love you I would hate it how
many sir how many successful people have
good childhoods zero I had a pretty
decent I don't know no you did it you
need to [ __ ] up your kids in order for
them to do well people have had and I
don't even think it's that [ __ ] up
like this is this is how she feels now
right
once the twins grow up maybe when the
twins are seven and desi turned into a
[ __ ] she might have a new post and
go my favorite are my two twins like
this I would have trust issues at that
point cuz I'd be like you [ __ ]
shape-shifting bit no but what if it's
twins are like so close with their dad
that that bond is like unbreakable and
she's like this is my best friend
because they are obsessed with him best
friends it's better than going my
favorite that's the same thing I would
say I would say he's my favorite
firstborn she put him she put him first
in her top
buying it something he needs leave like
that would have sent it straight up this
one's my favorite cousin listens this
one [ __ ] that one you either saying
this is but know this [ __ ] up Gio I'm
gonna stand with you on this because
here's what the here's what's in sweat
bro I'm disturbed so what's weird what's
weird about this to me is that nobody
asked her she's just coming up with this
comparison instead of like answering a
question she's like I want everyone to
know this is my favorite it's [ __ ]
weird you know why it's cuz those twins
are annoying as [ __ ] yeah they're one
well yeah but we live in a competitive
reality debuggers you can't just enjoy
things anymore they have to say how much
more they enjoy this than that how much
they more they enjoy this person than
that person instead of just saying what
they like it's like why I like this
person these all these people suck yeah
I think it's a bad habit I'm with it I
can see that I'm with it so these are
some comments once people [ __ ] too
much I like everybody equally
[ __ ] true I don't like everybody I
know some people who do their
subcultures really sexy okay if you
think you're sexy then you're [ __ ]
sexy that's called hell that's called
I'm gonna call back it's called the
illusion delusion nailed it it's comedy
hey listen that callback was 12 hours
ago they don't even know how they don't
know yeah but I made you laugh and
that's all I need
so some comments they say I feel so
sorry for your other boys I can't
imagine how this must make them feel it
thank you I wouldn't go out of my way to
comment that [ __ ] yeah those people good
suck a dick for me so sorry that these
kids are [ __ ] growing up with a
celebrity mom that got all this money
support me while they're kids [ __ ]
crying behind them then shut up and
[ __ ] leaving a comment on this is
ridiculous
literally any therapist would tell you
how damaging this is to your other
children I'm sure you're a great mom but
this was not a cool thing to put out
there forever that that person is a sec
addictive that's kind of true though
it's kind of true man I hope they learn
how to read that's insane that's an
insane thing to say when you have other
children I feel I feel poor I feel for
the others and how they
may feel after hearing and seeing I want
to verily abuse my children just to [ __ ]
and put into these [ __ ] faces I want
to get people to subscribe to this
YouTube channels well I want to do
because we're the only last remaining
place on YouTube that will actually say
whatever the [ __ ] we want if you say the
kids are [ __ ] faces here yeah and then
you can deal with consequences in real
life but not in the videos which is cool
so here's subscribe because we'll be
your guilty pleasure yeah and we'll set
you will sit the [ __ ] world strip I
feel like all these people that are just
talking [ __ ] they're uncomfortable and
being real yep they just come
face-to-face with it not some people
they want things to be so Disney and so
hallmark that when they're faced with
reality they're like oh [ __ ] this makes
me question how I feel about my kids
even though I have my own favorite - I
just want to hear that out loud because
these sorry [ __ ] were never the
favorite that's why do you have a
favorite I only have one right now if I
had I would right so we have to go hell
yeah and their favorite in different
ways for me so I like funny be even have
I even have a favorite body part on that
dog but on that dog I'm I like an actor
eyes more than their tail on the same
dog that's better
they're my favorites for different
reasons so they're both your favorite
yes thank you okay question though how
to help connect one-year-old compared to
12 year old you can have a conversation
with the 12 year old you can talk to him
all kind of [ __ ] 1 they're like nothing
your own chores I would have been like
she's young she's crazy choosing a 12
year old cuz the 1 year olds way [ __ ]
cuter no you didn't see them they were
ugly yeah I could I would I would always
chosen demon oh man
they're white they all look like mashed
potatoes because like I have nine
nephews and using white people are taken
in the shorts today I'm sorry I don't
think white babies are cute universally
Wow so here's some comments on the other
side one says I have six kids and I
always say my favorite is my firstborn
sorry he is I love them all but the
first is special no one says you are
amazing and I love this so much all his
parents have our favorite even though we
would give anything for all our kids
it's nice to see people openly say it
instead of denying it although if the
other two read this in the future you
could have a little problem
yeah but they could grow to be a face
for them right there that's real Everett
read the peasant good good what she
needs to say is favorites change don't
always compete for your favorites can't
change so if you're not the what are you
doing what are you doing that's [ __ ]
up my you should you can earn the spot
conditional later exactly yeah because
you might get straight A's and I might
make you my favorite bull see she loves
all three the same but favorites it's
not it's not the same yeah be like I
love you all three the same until one of
you [ __ ] up and that's not conditional
it's like it's like survivor you know
you got to play that with your kids yeah
listen I'm sure I'm sure that seafood
ramen was everyone's favorite until they
invented beef ramen why would seafood
come first I think it because it was the
first the fishes came first before the
calendar yeah you go to the Bible if you
go to the Bible I think the fishes were
created and then the land animals so
that's why they came out with seafood
ramen because they didn't have land
animals yet yeah I mean that's true that
it's actually just true because we
evolved from fish so thanks John okay
then I think about this sometimes to
where like because I want to have more
kids so I'm like damn wonder how
different it would be to like because I
already know what it's like having Isaac
and use my only kids I can't even
imagine having another kid and then what
that love for that kid would be like and
then to like compare it from like my
firstborn and then like the other kid is
just those thing where I'm like what is
that like I'd be like I loved you but
I'm
love this one even more an excellent
even more no man like I like I get what
she's saying cuz I think you know this
is your firstborn your oldest 12 years
have the most history the most history
like you grew up with your kid as well
but so I get those reasons but those
reasons wouldn't make them my favorite
I'm just saying I love you because of
these like these things are is what
makes it special but you're not my
favorite what if you have a boring ass
cuz you're gonna have the third kid that
you just relate to way more yeah and I'm
like you're not my favorite still but we
have weed you can hang out with that
cool it's 12 year old ever imagine Isaac
always mansplain to you all the [ __ ]
time right like toxic masculinity to the
max but then your second is exactly who
you are you guys think on the same
wavelength attack to the same things
like the same food he's a gay feminist
you might easily make the second one
your favorite now I mean I don't know
you've always got to keep them on their
toes yeah pretty much
I don't need kids I have all of yours
yeah cuz like I try to think the closest
thing I can relate it to is I have two
cats right like I didn't have one cat
longer than the other we got them both
at the same time and I love them each
but for different reasons but like I
don't know maybe it's like having twins
but let's say there's a burning house
and you only have one are because that
one got burned off by their neck fat
they'll be fine yeah oh [ __ ] I shoulda
thought of that accident really just lay
down die with us all of us guy Lee try
to run away no [ __ ] that's why you're
not my favorite
wait controversial question who do you
love more your child or each other for
me each other oh that is my biggest fear
about having kids I do not want my
husband to love something more than he
loves me fault I'm already gonna love my
kids before my wife and if I have a girl
I'm drowning her in the bathtub I'm just
kidding I already love my wife more than
any of my kids and I hope they're
watching this and I hope that they know
I'm gonna love my future kids more than
anything so [ __ ] my wife
[Music]